so continuing my series on the marvel
power hierarchy we pick up now with
those characters who are formidable but
are also considered to be earthbound now
when I say earthbound I don't mean
heroes and villains who simply reside on
earth since some of those individuals
like Franklin Richards stand among gods
despite being earthbound instead I mean
to say that we'll be focusing on
individuals from Earth who stand as the
planets most powerful beings not taking
into account those with godlike powers
so beginning with world war hulk in the
months prior to civil war Charles Xavier
Tony Stark Reed Richards Doctor Strange
and Black Bolt had made the decision to
send Hulk into space as a result of his
unstable mind and unpredictable actions
however where the intention of the
Illuminati was to send Hulk to a lush
planet during the trip he had been
pulled into a gravity well and ended up
on the other side of the galaxy on a
planet called Sicard finding himself
caught up in a revolution between the
red king who used flatter toriel games
for both his own entertainment and as a
means to keep the populace in line after
leading the revolutionary forces against
the red king and overthrowing his rule
Polk had settled down with one of the
revolutionary forces and eventually
formed a family of his own however
during this peaceful time and his hoax
transport ship was being turned into a
monument for his victory the warp core
was accidentally detonated resulting in
the annihilation of Hawk City and the
death of his family returning to Earth
and blaming the Illuminati for the
incident the world war hulk event
represents banner in his most angry form
and that by the time a story had ended
he had laid waste to the entirety of
Marvel's most powerful earthbound heroes
and it even stomped on the ground
shaking the entire East Coast of the
United States in the process as a result
the power that hope possesses during
this time made him the physically
strongest character in the world
something to also note here is that
while he was eventually defeated by
Robert Will's who fought Hulk to a
standstill
the success of this was due in part to
the fact that Reynolds admitted a type
of energy that was capable of calling
banner down meaning that Bruce strength
alone was not enough for Reynolds to
defeat the Hulk transitioning to eighth
day juggernaut under normal
circumstances the strength and various
abilities of K Marko use only a fraction
of the power provided by the demon
entities in Iraq to the Crimson gen
however because satiric exists as one of
eight entities who created various
artifacts for the purpose of using
humans in a wager determine which
the identity was the most powerful the
eighth day story arc saw the event
coming to fruition and came Arco endowed
with the full power of CID Iraq instead
of a fraction of those energies to this
end the powers of eighth day juggernaut
were multiplied several times over
making him equivalent to world breaker
Hulk and strength in addition to his
immortality having said that what I want
to do here is actually be a little
dangerous and there are some names into
the hat of people that I considered to
be on the same level as World War Hulk
n-ath other not study with Drax the
destroyer created from the corpse of a
man named Arthur Douglas whose family
had been presumed dead after Thanos had
attacked earth in an effort to acquire
the Cosmic Cube Drax the destroyer was
endowed with tremendous physical
strength on par with Thanos but lack the
same kind of intelligence making him the
quintessential meathead from here I want
to jump to Thor under the Warriors
madness now much like the Phoenix force
this could be considered Thor second
level and that while he does possess
incredible strength speed durability and
endurance when in the state of warriors
madness he quite literally loses himself
in bloodlust resulting in these various
attributes being magnified several times
over now cheating a little bit while
there are a multitude of other beings
who reside in this category I want to
pick up with Thanos whose story is
actually a little more complicated while
I do have a video with a full
explanation on his character the long
and short of this is that when the
Celestials experimented on primitive man
and form the deviants any Turtles while
the Eternals lived as gods and possess
those abilities some of them left earth
and took up residence on Saturn's moon
Titan
however because mutants deviants and
eternal is all stemmed from the same
gene Dallas was born as a mutant among
his own race and that he possessed the
powers of the Eternals but the physical
appearance of a deviant to this end the
base level of Thanos possess strength on
par with Hulk and his Roma form but
through mystical authentication by the
cosmic entity death and cybernetic
modification of his own design that
knows his powers for amplified several
times over making him equal in strength
to world breaker Hulk but also
possessing telepathy telekinesis limited
matter manipulation limited control over
the power cosmic and an intellect that
makes him far superior to any being on
earth
now picking up with Marvel's final lower
tiered characters I want to start by
focusing on Apocalypse well as various
abilities make him formidable in terms
of strength speed durability and
immortality on the whole these
enhancements are largely derived from
his interaction with celestial
technology allowing him to achieve
incredible feats but limiting those
powers to his involvement on earth now
our model does not explicitly pit
apocalypse against the likes of
characters like world breaker hope or
eighth date juggernaut they have
provided us with a medium to establish
exactly where apocalypse resides in
relation to those in Marvel's upper tier
in 1996 during the events of the
onslaught Saga which saw Charles Xavier
is frustration mingling with Magneto's
hatred for humanity and resulting in the
formation of onslaught as a psychic beam
while over watching the conflict
apocalypse was visited by The Watcher
who a - who argued that if in Subodh
noir stayed inactive onslaught would
destroy the world's heroes and begin his
conquest to start anew
where apocalypses actions saw him
partnering with cable and securing
franklin richards from the clutches of
onslaught model established that
apocalypses abilities paled in
comparison to what onslaught was capable
of in addition to this because onslaught
and will break or Hulk both reside on
the same level due to their believed to
challenge the heroes on earth we can
argue that apocalypse is incapable of
standing toe-to-toe with will breaker
Hulk in terms of strength speed and
durability now moving away from
apocalypse we begin to transition
downwards four most powerful two least
powerful beginning with spider-man
now repeater strength and durability
make him weaker than everyone here on
this list
aside from Wolverine Captain America and
Deadpool his placement is provided by
way of a spider sense
while Peter spider sense would be
useless against world breaker Hulk
juggernaut and others of the top tier
due to their limitless energies meeting
the fact that Peter would eventually
tire out in terms of others on this list
Peter spider sense allows him to keep
out of harm's way while analyzing the
best way to attack his foe and
neutralize the situation switch in a
dead room while he is one of the
physically weakest people on earth his
healing factor guarantees his
immortality which was established in the
funeral for a freak storyline where he
completely reformed from a single hand
now in truth figuring out where to put
Deadpool was actually a bit of a guess
on my end with his healing factor being
the only true attribute that allows him
to stand up is one of Earth's strongest
heroes his fighting prowess speed and
durability are all on par with a normal
person however because of metals like
carbonadium which exists as a cheaper
version of adamantium and produced by
the Russians it's radioactive principles
allow for the disruption of Deadpool's
human factor meaning that an individual
of the same fighting skill but wielding
a common Indian sword or a man of some
kind could easily embed fool by
temporarily disrupting this healing
factor and then placing laid in a form a
suspended animation now jumping to
Colossus much like juggernaut and Hulk
in their normal states the abilities of
Pietro and the strength that comes with
this organic metals form make him
impervious to all forms of damage with
the exception of adamantium guru metal
and vibranium with adamantium cutting
through Colossus metal skin bhura metal
containing magical Asgardian properties
and vibranium forcing Colossus to revert
to human form however barring an
encounter with these materials while in
his organic metal form Pietro grows by
one foil while being nine and vulnerable
to the elements with the exception of
extreme cold down the negative 150
degrees Fahrenheit and up to five
thousand degrees Fahrenheit as well as a
lack of need for food water and oxygen
finally and is a last example of this
group and one spend some time on Captain
America coming out of project rebirth
and the US government's desire to create
a super soldier after being introduced
to the serum which continually
rejuvenates itself within the body of
Rogers all his physical attributes
including strength endurance agility
speed reflexes in durability were
amplified several times over
making him equally capable to spider-man
but lacking a traditional spider sense
however because of his involvement in
various rewards throughout his life as
well as the enhancements that came
through martial arts training after his
rediscovery in Avengers issue number
four Captain America's lack of a spider
since it's compensated for by his
fighting experience allowing him to
predict the movements of others as a
kind of intuition when that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and let me know what you guys think
about this order I'm sure some people
are going to say something like you
didn't list my favorite character but
it's probably because your character
just fell into the mix with other
characters as I listed here but with
that being said I will catch you guys on
it
peace